well after a recent string of violent
incidents on the las vegas strip
one resort is launching a new security
program to keep their guests
safe thanks for joining us here at 11
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
win las vegas says their plan includes
screening all guests
and adding more security and police
officers article manna joining us now
live near the wind with the hotels and
also what tourists think about these
upgrades
orca well denise and brian win las vegas
says that the extra security measures
will be in place every weekend they want
guests to feel safe
especially given the recent uptick in
violence on this strip
tourists we spoke to say they hope it
works
on six of our main public doors we've
added
additional security stepping up security
at wynn las vegas the strip property
announcing strong security changes every
friday to sunday evening
that's also when you have your biggest
flow of people coming in when's vp of
security
todd fasulo tells me at the main
entrances and parking garages at the win
in the encore guests will be scanned for
metal objects and all handbags will be
screened the resort also adding more of
their own security officers and more
metro police officers
a lot of it has to do with not only
some of the incidents that have been on
the strip in the last few weeks
but also the winds desire to increase
our security and make our guests feel
safe
metro police say they've noticed an
uptick in violence at or near las vegas
strip property since
august which has already led to more
than 1100 arrests given the recent
shootings and fights taurus we spoke to
welcomed the winds changes
me personally i would feel safer you
know it's like knowing that there's
people ready
for any madness that may occur hopefully
not of course
that makes us feel safer you know we if
we're going to go into a casino we don't
want to see any
crazy people trying to hurt anybody else
win las vegas hoping this makes a
difference
we all have a responsibility to ensure
that our guests feel safe when they come
to our properties
now win las vegas plans to continue
these extra security measures for the
foreseeable future
by the way at tomorrow's clark county
commission meeting metro police is
expected to talk about the work
it's doing to combat violence on this
strip through a program
they call operation persistent pressure
reporting live near the las vegas strip
tonight orco mana 8 news now